hey guys welcome to vlog university if
you'll notice I'm wearing a beautiful
pirate eye patch that's because this
week's homework assignment is to create
a pirate video now this pirate video can
be pretty much anything that your little
imagination happens to dream huh
whether it's you being a pirate maybe
you're teaching someone to speak like a
pirate or maybe it's just you running
around with an eyepatch something crazy
now when you create your video be sure
to just add it as a video response to
this video you know what I'm taking this
eye patch off because I can't see
anything thank you to everyone who
submitted your homework for the last
challenge which was to create something
out of food whether it was drawn on food
bake some food or just create something
out of food now there are a bunch of
trends that I saw that you guys started
creating the first trend since I guess
is you know the winter holiday festive
season some of you guys made me some
snowmen out of probably my favorite
video out of the food creation category
was Mikey J's the video who made the
vlog University logo out of sunflower
seeds so this video is actually a little
bit creepy I mean I can't just qualify
it because it is food and tell me
something else said that was pretty cool
is a lot of you guys decided to make me
out of food which was pretty awesome
agency here's a few more of my favorite
videos thank you guys so much for
submitting your homework assignment for
last episode I look forward to seeing
what you guys are gonna do with a
pirate-themed episode I'm sure it's
gonna be amazing
be sure to subscribe so you'll know when
I launch new videos and check out I'll
look at the channels here on YouTube